bitcoin historically has been a pretty
volatile asset obviously right as
someone who has dealt more with maybe
traditional equity markets or things
like that and manages billions of
dollars for clients how do you get
individual clients comfortable with that
volatility
um
well you have to size it appropriately
so that's one of my issues in my core
fund if i put a four percent position
and the and it grows to 20
i have to probably scale it back so that
i can calm down my investors uh so what
i tell people if you're a bitcoin
maximus come into my bitcoin fund
if you're in my other fund let me size
it appropriately because it will be
volatile
um but you guys know this and i think
there's some historical perspective
necessary to share here
all these
medcap law
network effect investments
they start out in the early adoption
phase with mega volatility why
you've got all the fuddy-duddies and the
ancients shorting it disbelieving it
shorting tesla
shorting amazon amazon's gonna miss its
number it's 1999. let me short the
goddamn thing
and
they
create the volatility same thing happens
in bitcoin you know we hit an air pocket
uh with elon musk and china bitcoins at
65 000. it's at 29 000. i've got clients
lighting me up
and you guys know this everybody's a
long-term investor until they have
short-term losses when they have
short-term losses they set their hair on
fire they run around in a circle and so
i m one of my jobs is to be the
financial
and psychological coach i've got to tell
people calm down
uh stay the course we have a five-year
plan or a three-year plan
and i'll just point out because i think
it's worth mentioning if you were an
early investor in amazon
uh you know just think about this for a
second the ipo of amazon may 15 1997
a 10 000 investment is now worth 21
million dollars 21 million 140 000
however you would have had to subject
yourself to eight periods of time where
it dropped at least 50 percent
one period of time where it went down 85
and the barons newspaper had a front
page article amazon.com
the age of this internet retailer is
over
but the cat that made amazon jeff bezos
he shot himself into space in his own
rocket
okay so what do you guys want to do do
you want to
be patient
and look at something like bitcoin and
see the exponential growth of wallets
and the scale
and understand the value of the network
effect of those properties associated
there with
and stay patient
and watch bitcoin
eclipse gold in terms of its market
capitalization
or do you want to trade it and get juked
out of it at the wrong moment and do
what
non-psychologically minded investors do
is they sell lows and they buy highs
and so to me i got to get in the face i
got to get in i have to grab the face
mask of my clients and pull them close
to me like a good coach and say stop it
get your emotions out of this thing
this is a revolutionary asset this is
digital
waterfront property this is digital
energy
that is going to transform the world and
over the blockchain we are going to
de-layer
our society we're going to take third
party
intermediaries out of the society
there'll be a cost savings it'll be
ecologically friendly
there'll be quantum benefits associated
with this and you can own a piece of
this property today
at a very attractive price this is you
and me pomp going to miami beach in 1921
and buying oceanfront property facts